Speaker 1: Fox News breathlessly covered Donald
Trump flying from Florida to New York City for his
arrest. Almost like a soap opera. Truly stunning
where it is almost beyond parody, making him out
to be some kind of martyr. The coverage was led
by Harris Faulkner, whose right wing leanings,
at least as far as the character she plays on air.
Remember, Fox News hosts and anchors really are
characters at the end of the day, so she may be as
liberal as they come in her private life. I don't
know. But at least the right wing and right
wing character that Harris Faulkner plays has
become particularly weaponized over recent months.
Look at this. We're going to show you the entire
trajectory of this. Here is the coverage of Trump
leaving Mar a Lago to head to the airport to get
on his private plane. They call this news there.
Speaker 2: And now we've seen the second
car. Let's watch this live now. The
president number 45 for the night.
Speaker 1: By the way, the president
that the president is Joe Biden.
Speaker 2: States, is on the move to Palm Beach
International Airport. Wow. And as we grab these
photos, I just want to remind everybody the
types of decisions that have already been
made ahead of him arriving. Please. One of
them was the Secret Service, first of all,
is in charge of anything having to do with the
president. New York Police Department here in
the city will secure the streets, shall have
other presence inside the courtroom. Tomorrow,
when he is arraigned at 2:15 p.m. Eastern. But
for now, the Secret Service is in charge. And
so they've already made the kind of decision of
whether or not you would see him in handcuffs.
They had said no. They wanted to make sure that
wherever he's going to be had been swept. This
is a former president. We have never seen
anything like this. What we have seen. 1832
and then with four Agnew under Nixon, we
have seen former vice presidents and then
a sitting vice president with Spiro Agnew facing
indictment and charges. But what we have not seen
is a former commander in chief indicted in a
state now that he used to live in, doesn't live
there. And look at the people that are lined up
against the freeway. Everybody knows the route.
And this is a very, very short ride. I mean, yeah.
Speaker 1: It looks like mostly reporters filming,
quite frankly, but really making it almost like
a parade like atmosphere. And indeed, as they got
further in on the trip, it feels as though this
is like the Macy's Day Mesa, Thanksgiving Day,
Macy's Parade or something.
Speaker 2: And Kelly, I think,
is what you're telling me. I look at all these
people on the roadside and yes, some of them are
law enforcement, but a lot of these are citizens.
Speaker 1: Yes, some are law enforcement and some
are reporters with cameras. But there are some
citizens there, dozens potentially, of people.
Speaker 2: Who know this route. And he's going
to slow down a bit for this. Yeah, Apparently
he sent a box of hats out to some of those
who are peacefully gathered over the weekend.
Speaker 1: Yes, they were very, very I like
how now they always mention everybody's being
extraordinarily peaceful. And then really
a more philosophical question, my friends,
what is the destiny of Donald Trump as he boards
his private plane? What is coming in his future?
Speaker 2: His plane is getting ready to take off.
Now. They are on the move on the tarmac. And this
is what we have been watching for. And we don't
know what destiny looks like on the other side
of this trip when he gets here in New York City.
Speaker 1: Folks, this is a guy accused of crimes.
That's what this is. And they are turning him
into this martyr. Now, I know many of you have
already said, David, that's why it's going to help
him. The fact that they are turning him into the
victim and into this martyr. And it is expected
that Donald Trump tonight at his press conference
at Mar a Lago, is going to say, they didn't really
indict me. They indicted all of you. He is going
to frame this as a collective punishment of MAGA,
that they are punishing all of his supporters
for supporting him and for the greatest
political movement in history or whatever.
This is what has led to many of you writing to
me. Saying this is going to help him, David. This
is going to help him look at his fundraising
numbers. I concede readily that this in this
indictment. Okay. Let's let's wait before we say
future indictments. This indictment helps Trump
in the Republican primary. I agree with that. I
don't think that if there is another indictment
in Georgia and potentially a federal indictment,
that it will be good for Trump at all because
it really will hinder his ability to run his
campaign. And secondly, I don't understand how
this indictment gets Trump a single new vote in a
general election. This indictment and potentially
future indictments make Trump seem even more
chaotic than we've already known him to be and the
chaos that surrounds him. And so while this may
help Trump secure the Republican nomination, if
it doesn't end up interfering, if the indictments
keep coming. I think this is bad for Trump in a
general election. That's my view as of today.
If the facts change, I will revise that view